so I've become really interested in the
ways that human beings stabilize their
identity now I've talked before of
Cooley's theory of the looking glass
self this phenomenon known as peopling
in other words we come to be we emerge
as a thinking mind through the
interfacing through the socialization
with other thinking minds I am not who
you think I am I am not who I think I am
I am who I think you think I am and so
we only emerge as a self by creating
first a mental model of the other
person's interior world and then
furthermore creating a mental model of
that person's mental model modeling of
us and so it is constantly through this
reading and miss reading of other minds
that we kind of force appearance self
and this is very interesting because we
end up stabilizing this identity through
building bridges with all these
different kinds of people and forming
all these kinds of interpersonal
relationships that would kind of adjust
our sense of self depending on who we're
with you're a different person with your
friends you're a different person with
your parents you're a different person
with your siblings and/or children this
is a fascinating idea so in the context
of romantic relationships why are these
so wonderfully significant because you
know ever since Romeo and Juliet William
Shakespeare assured in this concept of
romantic love is the ultimate identity
affirming phenomenon in the world you
meet somebody in whose eyes you end up
finding yourself and anchoring yourself
in their heart body and mind
and so what happens when you break up
what happens when a relationship doesn't
work why is romantic heartbreak kind of
death brackets because human being
literally in without reservation go
through an identity dissolving
experience to break up with a romantic
partner is to see yourself dissolved in
the eyes of the way that they used to
see you think about that for a second
again the self is tethered to how we're
seeing through the eyes of others and
the person that we hold most significant
the chalice right that's the person that
we put on a pedestal when that collapses
right when you're gone who reveal their
clay feet you're left with not even
ourselves to make sense of this
implosion and this black hole is why
people have nervous breakdowns a lot of
the times when romantic relationships
fail now I've had my own experiences of
impassioned romantic unfoldings and I've
seen them disappear before my very eyes
and I'm telling you it's a difficult
thing to get through I mean to witness
your own identity dissolve and see your
tether rings and anchors implode is a
journey it's certainly it's an
experience and I guess my advice to
people is learn to distribute yourselves
and diversify your stock so to speak
don't put all your eggs in one basket I
know that doesn't sound too romance
the only way to save yourself in the
face of certain kind of hardship so yeah
you
[Music]